let's talk about your elevator pitch
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and this week we're gonna be
diving into a topic that I know is on
most of your minds how do I give a great
elevator pitch elevator pitches are
tough because most of us don't like
talking about ourselves especially in a
salesy way it feels weird it feels
inauthentic it it almost feels like
we're reading from a PowerPoint and all
too often when we actually go to an
event and give our pitch
we're met with this strange awkward
silence before someone starts talking
about the cheese dip or something I want
to help you avoid that awkward silence
so I did a little bit of research and I
found a newer approach to the elevator
pitch that I think is going to feel much
more authentic and be much more rooted
in your value than talking about a whole
bunch of random things that you may have
done in the last year this tip comes to
us from an excerpt from the marketing
plan handbook where Paul Carrack I hope
I said that name correctly
gives business owners an alternative to
the extremely boring PowerPoint pitch
that we're all so used to he calls it
the three-point elevator pitch formula
and I personally am extremely excited to
apply it and take it out on the road to
see how it performs the way it's listed
in this excerpt is primarily for
business owners selling their business
but we're going to tweak it slightly for
you and your job search part one ask a
question starting with the phrase do you
know this is something that is going to
reveal a pain point or a problem that
the person you're talking to likely has
experienced part two describe your
service or yourself using the phrase
what I do
this will help frame up the techniques
you use to solve that problem and part
three explain how your work or your
services solve that initial problem
using the phrase so that now this is all
very theoretical so let's put it into
action I'll use myself as an example as
though I'm in a
working scenario first they want me to
ask a question that identifies a pain my
response would be you know how the job
search can get extremely demotivating
especially with the high number of
rejections and non responses that you
receive online next I'm gonna describe
my skill set using the phrase of what I
do here's my response what I do is
create motivational and tactical career
content finally they want me to explain
why my work is valuable so my response
would be so that demotivated jobseekers
will get back to work and go out there
and find their dream job now let's bring
that all together you know how the job
search can get extremely demotivating
especially with the high number of
rejections and non responses that you
receive online what I do is create
motivational and tactical career content
so that demotivated jobseekers will get
back to work
and go out there and find their dream
job I'm not gonna lie this approach
feels way less awkward than what I was
doing even just a couple of weeks ago
when I was going out and giving my
elevator pitch while networking so I'm
really excited to see where you take it
and what you can come up with using this
formula and now I put the challenge to
you share a draft of your three-point
pitch in the comments and we can work on
it together we can really refine it and
make sure that it's as tight as possible
before you go out to your next event
bonus points if you create a video of
you giving your elevator pitch and tag
Udacity and myself so that we can see
your progress
that's it for this week thank you for
joining us again for another episode of
Udacity career tips I'm excited to bring
you more of these in the weeks to come
if you know anyone who's searching for a
job right now
tag them in the comments and let them
know you're thinking about them thank
you again and best of luck with your
search